This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Every morning, I wake up, roll over, pick up my phone, and check Twitter. I'm not proud of this, it's just the way it is. Twitter always struck me as the social media platform that was the most like broadcasting. It's an ongoing global conversation you can jump into, get a sense of what's going on in the world, and jump out. It's a lot like scanning through a radio dial, but it's mainly comprised of people you know and the people they know, telling you about their day, reacting to shocking news,
This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Every morning, I wake up, roll over, pick up my phone, and check Twitter. I'm not proud of this, it's just the way it is. Twitter always struck me as the social media platform that was the most like broadcasting. It's an ongoing global conversation you can jump into, get a sense of what's going on in the world, and jump out. It's a lot like scanning through a radio dial, but it's mainly comprised of people you know and the people they know, telling you about their day, reacting to shocking news,|||这里是“99%隐形”播客，我是罗曼·马斯。每天早晨，我醒来、翻身、拿起手机，然后刷推特。我对此并不引以为傲，但现实就是如此。推特给我的感觉一直是所有社交媒体平台中最像广播的。它是一场你可以随时加入、了解世界动态并随时退出的持续性全球对话。这很像是转动收音机调谐旋钮，但它主要由你认识的人以及他们认识的人组成，向你讲述他们的日常生活、对令人震惊的新闻做出反应，
making jokes, and sending around links. I tweeted Roman Mars by the way if you haven't heard me say that before. And sometimes I tweet at Truffleman. Because this producer's name is Avery Truffleman. But if you want to find out about the show in general, there's a hashtag for it. It's hashtag 999PI. The hashtag, of course, is comprised of two vertical lines intersecting two horizontal lines that looks like a tic-tac-toe board.
making jokes, and sending around links. I tweeted Roman Mars by the way if you haven't heard me say that before. And sometimes I tweet at Truffleman. Because this producer's name is Avery Truffleman. But if you want to find out about the show in general, there's a hashtag for it. It's hashtag 999PI. The hashtag, of course, is comprised of two vertical lines intersecting two horizontal lines that looks like a tic-tac-toe board.|||开玩笑，以及互相发送链接。顺便说一句，如果你没听我以前说过的话，我发过关于罗曼·马斯的推文。有时候我也会@Truffleman。因为这位制作人的名字叫艾弗里·特鲁夫曼。但如果你想了解整个节目的信息，有一个专属的话题标签。那就是#999PI。这个话题标签，当然是由两条垂直线与两条水平线相交组成的，看起来就像一个井字棋盘。
In the current digital world, the hashtag identifies movements, events, happenings, brands, topics of all kinds. Hashtags help people gather. That's incredible power to give to individuals. And as a character, I mean awesome. It's got this little typographic superhero story now. And this superhero story, stars Chris Messina. I'm Chris Messina, the inventor of the hashtag.
In the current digital world, the hashtag identifies movements, events, happenings, brands, topics of all kinds. Hashtags help people gather. That's incredible power to give to individuals. And as a character, I mean awesome. It's got this little typographic superhero story now. And this superhero story, stars Chris Messina. I'm Chris Messina, the inventor of the hashtag.|||在当今的数字世界中，话题标签可以识别各种运动、事件、时事、品牌和各种主题。话题标签帮助人们聚集在一起。赋予个人如此惊人的力量。而作为一个字符，我是说它太棒了。它现在有了一个微小的排版超级英雄故事。而这个超级英雄故事的主角是克里斯·梅西纳。我是克里斯·梅西纳，话题标签的发明者。
I'm a designer and translator. Translator? A human culture. That's probably a little bit bloated. I don't know. I don't know what I do. Chris was the first one to use a hashtag on Twitter before it was even called a hashtag. Back in August of 2007 when he was going to an event called BarCamp. It's an nerdy thing. It's totally nerdy thing. It's an event that you go to that's completely unstructured and unplanned and the participants figure it out. So the participants needed a way of organizing, which led Chris to tweet the very first hashtag, even though at that point it was just a pound sign. How do you guys feel about using pound barcamp for groups?
I'm a designer and translator. Translator? A human culture. That's probably a little bit bloated. I don't know. I don't know what I do. Chris was the first one to use a hashtag on Twitter before it was even called a hashtag. Back in August of 2007 when he was going to an event called BarCamp. It's an nerdy thing. It's totally nerdy thing. It's an event that you go to that's completely unstructured and unplanned and the participants figure it out. So the participants needed a way of organizing, which led Chris to tweet the very first hashtag, even though at that point it was just a pound sign. How do you guys feel about using pound barcamp for groups?|||我是一名设计师和翻译。翻译？人类文化的翻译。这可能有点夸大其词了。我不知道。我不知道我在做什么。克里斯是在推特上第一个使用井号的人，当时它甚至还不叫话题标签。那是2007年8月，他要去参加一个叫BarCamp的活动。这是一件书呆子气的事。完全是书呆子气的事。这是一个你参加的完全没有结构、没有计划、由参与者自己摸索的活动。所以参与者需要一种组织方式，这促使克里斯发出了有史以来的第一个话题标签，尽管当时它只是一个井号。大家觉得用井号加barcamp来作为群组标识怎么样？
Putting a pound sign in front of the word barcamp helps the other people at barcamp pick out the word barcamp in their Twitter stream And encourages all the other barcamp participants to use the word barcamp in their tweets So now everyone who's interested in barcamp can search for that term and join the conversation Now let's hope I never have to use the word barcamp again So some people got on board and agreed to use the pound sign But most were like, okay, you go do that. The pound symbol had already pervaded other corners of the web. Internet Relay Chat, aka IRC, used the pound sign to represent chat rooms or conversation channels.
Putting a pound sign in front of the word barcamp helps the other people at barcamp pick out the word barcamp in their Twitter stream And encourages all the other barcamp participants to use the word barcamp in their tweets So now everyone who's interested in barcamp can search for that term and join the conversation Now let's hope I never have to use the word barcamp again So some people got on board and agreed to use the pound sign But most were like, okay, you go do that. The pound symbol had already pervaded other corners of the web. Internet Relay Chat, aka IRC, used the pound sign to represent chat rooms or conversation channels.|||在barcamp这个词前面加上一个井号，可以帮助barcamp的其他人在他们的推特信息流中挑出barcamp这个词，并鼓励所有其他barcamp参与者在他们的推文中也使用barcamp这个词。所以现在每个对barcamp感兴趣的人都可以搜索这个词并加入对话。现在希望我再也不用使用barcamp这个词了。所以有些人加入了进来，同意使用井号。但大多数人觉得，好吧，你自己去弄吧。井号已经渗透到了网络的其他角落。互联网中继聊天，又称IRC，用井号来代表聊天室或对话频道。
There was another social network at the time called Jikoo that also had these channels. So there was other stuff that came before me. But Chris was using bunches of pound signs throughout his tweets. I was putting pound symbols in front of my words. And people were like, I don't understand what you're doing. You're putting all the strange punctuation in front of your stuff and it looks dumb. But the true believers stood by the sign.
There was another social network at the time called Jikoo that also had these channels. So there was other stuff that came before me. But Chris was using bunches of pound signs throughout his tweets. I was putting pound symbols in front of my words. And people were like, I don't understand what you're doing. You're putting all the strange punctuation in front of your stuff and it looks dumb. But the true believers stood by the sign.|||当时还有一个叫Jikoo的社交网络，也有这些频道。所以在我之前还有其他东西。但克里斯在他的推文中到处都在使用一束束的井号。我一直在我的词前面加上井号。人们就会说，我搞不懂你在干什么。你在你的东西前面加上所有这些奇怪的标点符号，看起来太蠢了。但真正的信徒们支持这个符号。
One Twitter user called it a hash tag because hash is the British name for the sign. And these were being used as category tags. And then the hash and the tag got conjoined into one word. Chris actually brought the hashtag idea to Twitter headquarters directly, but they thought it would never catch on. It looked clunky.
One Twitter user called it a hash tag because hash is the British name for the sign. And these were being used as category tags. And then the hash and the tag got conjoined into one word. Chris actually brought the hashtag idea to Twitter headquarters directly, but they thought it would never catch on. It looked clunky.|||一个推特用户称它为“hash tag”（哈希标签），因为hash是英国人对这个符号的称呼。而这些当时正被用作分类标签。然后hash和tag就被连成了一个词。克里斯实际上直接将话题标签的想法带到了推特总部，但他们认为这永远不会流行起来。它看起来太笨拙了。
Then a few months later in October of 2007, the purpose of the hashtag was fully realized. A friend of mine was down in San Diego, his name's Nate Ritter, and he was using Twitter, basically pulling all this stuff together around these fires that were going on in San Diego. Wildfires were raging around San Diego, and residents were tracking the spread through Nate Ritter's tweets.
Then a few months later in October of 2007, the purpose of the hashtag was fully realized. A friend of mine was down in San Diego, his name's Nate Ritter, and he was using Twitter, basically pulling all this stuff together around these fires that were going on in San Diego. Wildfires were raging around San Diego, and residents were tracking the spread through Nate Ritter's tweets.|||几个月后，即2007年10月，话题标签的作用得到了充分体现。我的一个朋友在圣迭戈，名叫内特·里特，他当时在使用推特，基本上把圣迭戈发生的这些大火相关的所有信息都汇总在一起。野火在圣迭戈周围肆虐，居民们通过内特·里特的推文追踪火势蔓延情况。
But he was prefixing all of his tweets with San's face Diego space fire. So Chris told Nate that he should switch to hashtag San Diego Fire, all one word, and then other users would imitate him. And it worked. People trying to find out about the fire knew exactly where to look on Twitter.
But he was prefixing all of his tweets with San's face Diego space fire. So Chris told Nate that he should switch to hashtag San Diego Fire, all one word, and then other users would imitate him. And it worked. People trying to find out about the fire knew exactly where to look on Twitter.|||但他所有的推文都以“圣迭戈火灾”（San Diego fire）为前缀，中间留有空格。因此克里斯告诉内特，他应该改成“#圣迭戈火灾”（#SanDiegoFire，连成一个词），然后其他用户就会模仿他。这真的奏效了。想要了解火灾情况的人准确地知道了在推特上哪里可以找到相关信息。
And this was a moment where everyone went, oh, that's what these signs are for. Now to clarify, hashtags weren't a thing that Twitter planned on. And they kind of dragged their feet on incorporating it. We kept thinking there must be a better way to organize all this information that's flying through Twitter. We kept looking for it, we never really found it.
And this was a moment where everyone went, oh, that's what these signs are for. Now to clarify, hashtags weren't a thing that Twitter planned on. And they kind of dragged their feet on incorporating it. We kept thinking there must be a better way to organize all this information that's flying through Twitter. We kept looking for it, we never really found it.|||这也是一个让所有人恍然大悟的时刻：哦，原来这些符号是干这个用的。需要澄清的是，话题标签并不是推特计划中的功能。他们在整合这一功能时有点拖延。我们一直认为，肯定有一种更好的方法来组织在推特上飞速传播的所有这些信息。我们一直在寻找，但从未真正找到。
But the hashtag and retrospect was just this obvious tool. Andy Lorich, then an employee at Twitter, officially brought in the hashtag. The users brought in the hashtag. What all I did was link the hashtag to Twitter search. One line of code took me about 15 seconds, didn't really ask anybody. That one line of code meant that when you clicked on a word with a hashtag in front of it, you'd see a page with all the other tweets that also contained that hashtag word. And basically, this helped you round up everyone who was talking about a specific topic.
But the hashtag and retrospect was just this obvious tool. Andy Lorich, then an employee at Twitter, officially brought in the hashtag. The users brought in the hashtag. What all I did was link the hashtag to Twitter search. One line of code took me about 15 seconds, didn't really ask anybody. That one line of code meant that when you clicked on a word with a hashtag in front of it, you'd see a page with all the other tweets that also contained that hashtag word. And basically, this helped you round up everyone who was talking about a specific topic.|||但回想起来，话题标签就是这么一个显而易见的工具。安迪·洛里奇，当时推特的一名员工，正式引入了话题标签。是用户带来了话题标签。我所做的全部工作就是将话题标签链接到推特搜索。一行代码花了我大约15秒钟，也没怎么征求别人的同意。那行代码意味着，当你点击一个前面带有话题标签的词时，你会看到一个页面，上面显示了所有包含该话题标签词的其他推文。基本上，这帮你在全网搜罗了所有讨论特定话题的人。
And now the hashtag is a tool used in advertisements, social movements, music videos, memes, TV shows. And in conversation, hashtag sometimes. Hey, Justin, what's up? No much to me. Hashtag challenge, what would you? It's been busy working. Hashtag rising groined. Hashtag is it Friday yet?
And now the hashtag is a tool used in advertisements, social movements, music videos, memes, TV shows. And in conversation, hashtag sometimes. Hey, Justin, what's up? No much to me. Hashtag challenge, what would you? It's been busy working. Hashtag rising groined. Hashtag is it Friday yet?|||现在，话题标签已经成为广告、社会运动、音乐录影带、表情包、电视节目中使用的工具。在对话中，有时也会用到话题标签。嘿，贾斯汀，怎么了？没什么。#挑战，你会怎么做？一直在忙着工作。#腹股沟拉伤。#今天是周五吗？
Even Chris acknowledges how irritating this is. Do you say it out loud? Mostly what I'm being annoying or ironic. but I'm coming to accept that that's the phrase. It's getting to the point where the hashtag is erasing the symbols other uses. A friend of mine sent me a tweet the other day saying that he is delivery guy showed up and was looking for a hashtag to A. Though I'd hope that most people who make deliveries for a living hashtag SMH would know
Even Chris acknowledges how irritating this is. Do you say it out loud? Mostly what I'm being annoying or ironic. but I'm coming to accept that that's the phrase. It's getting to the point where the hashtag is erasing the symbols other uses. A friend of mine sent me a tweet the other day saying that he is delivery guy showed up and was looking for a hashtag to A. Though I'd hope that most people who make deliveries for a living hashtag SMH would know|||连克里斯也承认这有多烦人。你会大声说出来吗？通常当我感到烦人或讽刺的时候。但我开始接受这就是这种说法。现在情况发展到话题标签正在抹去这个符号的其他用途。前几天我的一个朋友给我发了一条推特，说他的送货员来了，正在找一个A字形的话题标签（井号）。虽然我希望大多数以送货为生的人#无语（SMH）会知道
it more as a number sign. In the States, it's usually called the number sign or the pound sign. In the UK, it's often called a hash mark, I think more because of the way it looks than anything else. This is Keith Houston. He's the author of a book called Shady Characters, the secret life of punctuation symbols and other typographical marks.
it more as a number sign. In the States, it's usually called the number sign or the pound sign. In the UK, it's often called a hash mark, I think more because of the way it looks than anything else. This is Keith Houston. He's the author of a book called Shady Characters, the secret life of punctuation symbols and other typographical marks.|||它更多是一个数字符号。在美国，它通常被称为数字符号或磅符号。在英国，它通常被称为哈希符号（hash mark），我觉得这更多是因为它的外观而不是别的什么原因。这是基斯·休斯顿。他是《隐秘的字符：标点符号和其他印刷符号的秘密生活》一书的作者。
It's got a whole chapter on this symbol. And it has a lot of other random uses as well. It's used in chess to represent a move of the results in checkmate. In proofreading, if you see a hash symbol, this means a space should be inserted here. It's used on Swedish maps to mean a lumber yard. Hash, pound, number sign, lumber yard, whatever you want to call it, however you want to use
It's got a whole chapter on this symbol. And it has a lot of other random uses as well. It's used in chess to represent a move of the results in checkmate. In proofreading, if you see a hash symbol, this means a space should be inserted here. It's used on Swedish maps to mean a lumber yard. Hash, pound, number sign, lumber yard, whatever you want to call it, however you want to use|||书里有一整章都在讲这个符号。它还有许多其他随意的用途。它在国际象棋中用来表示导致将死的走法。在校对中，如果你看到一个哈希符号，这意味着这里应该插入一个空格。它在瑞典地图上用来表示木材场。哈希符号、磅符号、数字符号、木材场，无论你想怎么称呼它，无论你想怎么使用
it. The symbol traces back to ancient Rome. So in Rome, the term Libra Pondo meant a pound and weight. So the word Libra, like the constellation means scales or balances, and Pondo comes from the very penderi which means to weigh. Libra Pondo and these two names were interchangeable, so Romans referred to this weight measurement as a Libra, or a Pondo. So the word Libra was often abbreviated as Lb. Lowercase L, lowercase B, which of course we still use.
it. The symbol traces back to ancient Rome. So in Rome, the term Libra Pondo meant a pound and weight. So the word Libra, like the constellation means scales or balances, and Pondo comes from the very penderi which means to weigh. Libra Pondo and these two names were interchangeable, so Romans referred to this weight measurement as a Libra, or a Pondo. So the word Libra was often abbreviated as Lb. Lowercase L, lowercase B, which of course we still use.|||它。这个符号可以追溯到古罗马。在罗马，术语Libra Pondo意思是重量为一磅。所以Libra这个词，就像星座一样意为天平或秤，而Pondo源于意为称重的penderi一词。Libra Pondo这两个名字是可以互换的，所以罗马人将这种重量测量单位称为Libra或Pondo.因此Libra这个词经常被简写为Lb。小写的l，小写的b，我们当然现在还在使用。
So if you see 5 Lb, you mean 5 Libra or 5 pounds in the Latin sense. This is also why British currency, the pound, is represented by a stylized L for Libra. So the abbreviation LB becomes a thing, and oftentimes it was drawn with a little bar across the tops of both letters, just to show that the L and the B were connected. Scribes, our writers, got a bit careless,
So if you see 5 Lb, you mean 5 Libra or 5 pounds in the Latin sense. This is also why British currency, the pound, is represented by a stylized L for Libra. So the abbreviation LB becomes a thing, and oftentimes it was drawn with a little bar across the tops of both letters, just to show that the L and the B were connected. Scribes, our writers, got a bit careless,|||所以如果你看到5 Lb，你的意思是5 Libra或拉丁语意义上的5磅。这也是为什么英国货币“英镑”（pound）用一个代表Libra的风格化字母L来表示。因此缩写LB成了一种常见符号，而且通常在两个字母的顶部画上一条小横线，只是为了表明L和B是连在一起的。抄写员，我们的文人，变得有点粗心，
so they'd write faster and faster and faster, so you join the L to the B, and then maybe the pen doesn't leave the paper before it does the little bar across the top. And so this seems to have given rise to the pound symbol. Or hash mark, or lumber yard. Over time, the symbols meaning started to bifurcate. It was used like LB for the unit pound, and it also started to be used as a number sign. It had a lot of various uses.
so they'd write faster and faster and faster, so you join the L to the B, and then maybe the pen doesn't leave the paper before it does the little bar across the top. And so this seems to have given rise to the pound symbol. Or hash mark, or lumber yard. Over time, the symbols meaning started to bifurcate. It was used like LB for the unit pound, and it also started to be used as a number sign. It had a lot of various uses.|||所以他们写得越来越快，把L和B连起来写，然后可能笔还没离开纸就顺手在顶部画了那道小横线。于是这似乎就衍生出了磅符号。或者是哈希符号，或是木材场。随着时间的推移，这个符号的含义开始分化。它既像LB一样用于表示重量单位磅，也开始被用作数字符号。它有很多不同的用途。
But it was important enough to wind up on typewriter keyboards, which is kind of the key thing, it's the thing that a symbol had to do in order to survive. Because symbols that didn't make it onto the typewriter keyboard got pretty unpopular, like the intero bang, or the pill-crow, or the manicure, these poor things. Fast forward to 1963, the invention of the touch-tone telephone. Hi, this is the Bell Systems new touch-tone dialing. The touch-tone phone used buttons instead of a rotary wheel. So unlike previous phones, the numbers didn't have to be arranged in a circle on the dial anymore.
But it was important enough to wind up on typewriter keyboards, which is kind of the key thing, it's the thing that a symbol had to do in order to survive. Because symbols that didn't make it onto the typewriter keyboard got pretty unpopular, like the intero bang, or the pill-crow, or the manicure, these poor things. Fast forward to 1963, the invention of the touch-tone telephone. Hi, this is the Bell Systems new touch-tone dialing. The touch-tone phone used buttons instead of a rotary wheel. So unlike previous phones, the numbers didn't have to be arranged in a circle on the dial anymore.|||但它足够重要，最终登上了打字机键盘，这可以说是关键所在——这是一个符号为了生存必须做到的事情。因为那些未能登上打字机键盘的符号变得很不受欢迎，比如反问叹号（intero bang）、段落号（pill-crow）或手形符号（manicure），这些可怜的东西。快进到1963年，双音多频电话的发明。嗨，这是贝尔系统的全新双音多频拨号。双音多频电话使用按键而不是旋转拨号盘。因此，与以前的电话不同，数字不再需要在拨号盘上排成一个圆圈。
Bell Laboratories, a research subsidiary of AT&T, experimented with a few different designs for the telephone keypad. They tried arranging the numbers in two rows of five, in a circle, and a cross, and a step pattern. But they ended up arranging the numbers one through nine in a three by three grid, and they put zero alone in the bottom center.
Bell Laboratories, a research subsidiary of AT&T, experimented with a few different designs for the telephone keypad. They tried arranging the numbers in two rows of five, in a circle, and a cross, and a step pattern. But they ended up arranging the numbers one through nine in a three by three grid, and they put zero alone in the bottom center.|||贝尔实验室是AT&T旗下的研究子公司，他们为电话键盘尝试了几种不同的设计。他们尝试过将数字排成两行每行五个、排成圆圈、十字形以及阶梯形。但他们最终决定将1到9的数字排列成3乘3的网格，并将数字0单独放在底部正中央。
Years later, in 1968 they figured why not add keys to either side of the zero. This would make the keypad into a nice even rectangle and give users a few more options on the phone menu. To repeat these options press the star key. Because unlike rotary phones, touch-tone phones allow you to continue to dial after the connection has been made. So you could punch in extensions and navigate automated menus. Originally Bell Labs wanted pretty shapes on the two extra buttons.
Years later, in 1968 they figured why not add keys to either side of the zero. This would make the keypad into a nice even rectangle and give users a few more options on the phone menu. To repeat these options press the star key. Because unlike rotary phones, touch-tone phones allow you to continue to dial after the connection has been made. So you could punch in extensions and navigate automated menus. Originally Bell Labs wanted pretty shapes on the two extra buttons.|||几年后的1968年，他们想，为什么不在0的两侧各加一个按键呢。这会使键盘变成一个整齐匀称的长方形，并为用户在电话菜单中提供更多选项。要重复这些选项，请按星号键。因为与旋转式电话不同，双音多频电话允许你在接通后继续拨号。因此你可以输入分机号并浏览自动语音菜单。最初贝尔实验室希望在这两个额外的按钮上有好看的形状。
They had made prototype phones that had a 5-pointed star and a diamond on either side of the zero. But an engineer named Doug Kerr would have none of this diamond and five-point star business. Because by that time a new thing had come into the picture, the possibility of customers dialing directly from their phones into a computer for such things as checking bank balances or validating their credit cards or what have you. Doug Kerr wanted to make sure that the two new symbols would be one's a computer could recognize.
They had made prototype phones that had a 5-pointed star and a diamond on either side of the zero. But an engineer named Doug Kerr would have none of this diamond and five-point star business. Because by that time a new thing had come into the picture, the possibility of customers dialing directly from their phones into a computer for such things as checking bank balances or validating their credit cards or what have you. Doug Kerr wanted to make sure that the two new symbols would be one's a computer could recognize.|||他们制作过原型电话，在0的两侧分别有五角星和菱形。但一个名叫道格·克尔（Doug Kerr）的工程师坚决反对这种菱形和五角星的方案。因为当时出现了一项新事物——客户有可能直接通过电话拨号连入计算机，用于查询银行余额、验证信用卡或做其他类似事情。道格·克尔希望确保这两个新符号是计算机能够识别的符号。
One's that appear on a keyboard and we're part of the computer's vocabulary. So there would be no uncertainty about how a certain button would be recorded in the data that went into the computer. Bell Labs was pretty set on their star and diamond idea. So the compromise was an asterisk for the star and a pound for the diamond because, you know, the center kind of looked diamond like, I guess. And for a second AT&T was like, can we at least call it a diamond? There's no reasonable reason to call that symbol diamond.
One's that appear on a keyboard and we're part of the computer's vocabulary. So there would be no uncertainty about how a certain button would be recorded in the data that went into the computer. Bell Labs was pretty set on their star and diamond idea. So the compromise was an asterisk for the star and a pound for the diamond because, you know, the center kind of looked diamond like, I guess. And for a second AT&T was like, can we at least call it a diamond? There's no reasonable reason to call that symbol diamond.|||那些出现在键盘上并且是计算机词汇一部分的符号。这样一来，某个按键如何在进入计算机的数据中被记录就不会存在任何不确定性。贝尔实验室非常坚持他们的星星和菱形方案。所以折中的办法是用星号（asterisk）代替星星，用井号代替菱形，因为，你知道的，我猜它的中心看起来有点像菱形。有一会儿，AT&T甚至说：“我们至少能把它叫作菱形吗？”没有任何合理的理由把那个符号叫作菱形。
It's not a diamond at all. AT&T didn't know what to call this button in their manuals, and this led to the creation of what some people, including Keith Houston, consider the symbol's official name. The Oxothorpe. the Octathorpe. One day I was out with my engineering partner, and we got to talking about it, and thought maybe we should come up with a new name. This is Lauren Aspland.
It's not a diamond at all. AT&T didn't know what to call this button in their manuals, and this led to the creation of what some people, including Keith Houston, consider the symbol's official name. The Oxothorpe. the Octathorpe. One day I was out with my engineering partner, and we got to talking about it, and thought maybe we should come up with a new name. This is Lauren Aspland.|||它根本就不是菱形。AT&T不知道在手册中该如何称呼这个按钮，这促使人们创造了一个被包括基斯·休斯顿在内的一些人认为是该符号官方名称的词。Oxothorpe。Octathorpe。有一天我和我的工程搭档外出，我们聊起了这个，觉得或许我们应该想出一个新名字。这是劳伦·阿斯普兰（Lauren Aspland）。
He worked in marketing for AT&T during the time. He and his engineering partner looked at the symbol and saw that it had eight lines sticking out of it. So we'll put the word Octo in there, and then just out of thin air, we just said, well, we'll put the word FERP, TH, ERP in there too, because that sounds kind of Greekish
He worked in marketing for AT&T during the time. He and his engineering partner looked at the symbol and saw that it had eight lines sticking out of it. So we'll put the word Octo in there, and then just out of thin air, we just said, well, we'll put the word FERP, TH, ERP in there too, because that sounds kind of Greekish|||他当时在AT&T从事市场营销工作。他和他的工程搭档看着这个符号，发现它有八条突出的线条。所以我们在里面加上“Octo”（八）这个词，然后凭空造词，我们说，好吧，我们把“FERP”（或TH-ERP）这个词也加进去，因为这听起来有点像希腊语
and give us some stature. They called it an octo-thirp, but that morphed into octo-thorpe, which rumor has it came about because someone at Bell Labs changed the name to turn it into a tribute to Olympic athlete Jim Thorpe. But no one really knows. G. is it proper to spell it?
and give us some stature. They called it an octo-thirp, but that morphed into octo-thorpe, which rumor has it came about because someone at Bell Labs changed the name to turn it into a tribute to Olympic athlete Jim Thorpe. But no one really knows. G. is it proper to spell it?|||并能赋予我们一些地位。他们称之为“octo-thirp”，但后来演变成“octo-thorpe”，有传言说这是因为贝尔实验室的某个人改了名字，是为了向奥运会运动员吉姆·索普（Jim Thorpe）致敬。但没有人真正知道。G，这样拼写合适吗？
Octo Thorpe? Rather than Thorpe, there is no proper. Doug calls it an octo Thorpe. Lauren calls it an octo Thorpe. But octo Thorpe seems to have the most widespread use. Though it's use is not widely spread. And originally the only reason Octo Thorurp ever caught on within Bell Labs was because engineers thought it was a funny joke.
Octo Thorpe? Rather than Thorpe, there is no proper. Doug calls it an octo Thorpe. Lauren calls it an octo Thorpe. But octo Thorpe seems to have the most widespread use. Though it's use is not widely spread. And originally the only reason Octo Thorurp ever caught on within Bell Labs was because engineers thought it was a funny joke.|||Octo Thorpe？而不是Thorpe，没有什麽正统不正统的。道格叫它octo Thorpe。劳伦也叫它octo Thorpe。但octo Thorpe似乎使用最为广泛。尽管它的使用其实并不算广泛。最初“Octo-Thorup”在贝尔实验室内部流传的唯一原因，只是因为工程师们觉得这是一个好笑的玩笑。
The manufacturer, Western Electric, totally hated that name and pretty much killed it in the 70s. But today for a lot of type of fishing autos, Octo Thurp is the sign's real name. In typographic books, Octo Thurp is the name used. You might think of it as a technical term. Typographic nerds like Keith love it because it feels the most neutral and official. But in choosing this symbol, whatever it's called, Doug Kerr and the other Bell Labs engineers really understood that we would be using telephones to communicate with computers.
The manufacturer, Western Electric, totally hated that name and pretty much killed it in the 70s. But today for a lot of type of fishing autos, Octo Thurp is the sign's real name. In typographic books, Octo Thurp is the name used. You might think of it as a technical term. Typographic nerds like Keith love it because it feels the most neutral and official. But in choosing this symbol, whatever it's called, Doug Kerr and the other Bell Labs engineers really understood that we would be using telephones to communicate with computers.|||制造商西方电气公司（Western Electric）极其讨厌这个名字，并在70年代几乎将其废弃。但今天对于许多排版爱好者来说，“Octo Thurp”才是这个符号的真名。在排版书籍中，“Octo Thurp”是被使用的名称。你可能会认为这是一个专业术语。像基斯这样的排版发烧友非常喜欢它，因为它感觉最中立、最官方。但在选择这个符号时——无论它叫什么名字——道格·克尔和其他贝尔实验室的工程师确实明白，我们将使用电话与计算机进行通信。
And this is exactly the same reason why Chris Messina chose to use this symbol back in that tweet in 2007. At the time, we had blackberries, we had no key phones, and these are hardware-based keyboards. But we need something that works in the mobile world, and we need something that works over SMS, because that's the way that I'm going to be publishing to Twitter. Which left Chris only two choices, the star or the pound.
And this is exactly the same reason why Chris Messina chose to use this symbol back in that tweet in 2007. At the time, we had blackberries, we had no key phones, and these are hardware-based keyboards. But we need something that works in the mobile world, and we need something that works over SMS, because that's the way that I'm going to be publishing to Twitter. Which left Chris only two choices, the star or the pound.|||这与克里斯·梅西纳在2007年的那条推文中选择使用这个符号的原因完全相同。当时，我们有黑莓手机，我们有诺基亚手机，这些都是基于硬件的键盘。但我们需要一个能在移动世界中起作用的东西，我们需要一个能通过短信（SMS）工作的工具，因为那是我将要发布推特的方式。这使得克里斯只有两个选择：星号或井号。
The pound symbol, the artthorpe, whatever. It's probably one of the most dense symbols. And so when you're reading a sentence or you're reading a tweet, it stands out. And so you see hashtags on billboards on the highway, on promotional materials, on other social media platforms, on protest signs, in your annoying friends' conversations. I'm just going to show my dentist hashtag, bling, hashtag dental care, hashtag cavity free, hashtag, that's how we do! And this is all probably going to sound so dated in like five years
The pound symbol, the artthorpe, whatever. It's probably one of the most dense symbols. And so when you're reading a sentence or you're reading a tweet, it stands out. And so you see hashtags on billboards on the highway, on promotional materials, on other social media platforms, on protest signs, in your annoying friends' conversations. I'm just going to show my dentist hashtag, bling, hashtag dental care, hashtag cavity free, hashtag, that's how we do! And this is all probably going to sound so dated in like five years|||磅符号、octathorpe，随便叫什么吧。它可能是结构最密集的符号之一。因此，当你阅读一个句子或阅读一条推文时，它格外显眼。于是你会看到话题标签出现在高速公路的广告牌上、宣传材料上、其他社交媒体平台上、抗议标语上、以及你那烦人的朋友们的谈话中。“我正要去看牙医，#bling，#牙齿护理，#没有蛀牙，#这就是我们的风格！”所有这些在大概五年后听起来都会过时
or two years or maybe a few months. Hearing hashtag out loud is going to sound like someone reading a telegram. Mr. Gower cable, you need cash stuff. My office instructed to advance to up to $25,000 dollar. He, Ha, and Mary Christmas, Sam Wayne Wright. In a telegram, as on Twitter, our speech changed to accommodate the machines. The hashtag is a way of changing our language to be more computer friendly.
or two years or maybe a few months. Hearing hashtag out loud is going to sound like someone reading a telegram. Mr. Gower cable, you need cash stuff. My office instructed to advance to up to $25,000 dollar. He, Ha, and Mary Christmas, Sam Wayne Wright. In a telegram, as on Twitter, our speech changed to accommodate the machines. The hashtag is a way of changing our language to be more computer friendly.|||或者两年，甚至几个月。大声说出“hashtag”听起来就像有人在读电报。“加尔先生，电汇，你需要现金。我办公室指示预支最高2.5万美元。呵呵，圣诞快乐，萨姆·韦恩赖特。”在电报中，就像在推特上一样，我们的语言为了适应机器而发生了改变。话题标签就是一种改变我们的语言以使其对计算机更友好的方式。
And what we're needing to do is actually invert the paradigm where the computers become more friendly to humans. So we're probably not going to be using hashtags the way Twitter uses hashtags forever. But this won't mean the end of the symbol itself. It started out on paper, but then it leaped to typebredders, computers, and phones, and it seems like it's probably going to stick around. Whatever we decide to call it.
And what we're needing to do is actually invert the paradigm where the computers become more friendly to humans. So we're probably not going to be using hashtags the way Twitter uses hashtags forever. But this won't mean the end of the symbol itself. It started out on paper, but then it leaped to typebredders, computers, and phones, and it seems like it's probably going to stick around. Whatever we decide to call it.|||而我们需要做的是实际上颠倒这种范式，让计算机对人类更加友好。因此，我们可能不会永远像推特那样使用话题标签。但这并不意味着这个符号本身的终结。它起源于纸张，但随后跃升至打字机、计算机和手机上，而且它看起来可能会一直存在下去。无论我们决定叫它什么。
Hashtag Octathorp, Hashtag Octathurp, Hashtag Pound, Hashtag Number Sign, Hashtag Lumberyard, Hashtag Tiktok Do, Hashtag Musical Sharp if you're really lazy. Stop. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Avery Troubleman with same green span Katie Mingle and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and produced out of the offices of ArcSign an architecture and interiors firm in beautiful, downtown Oakland, California. I also invented the Caps Lock key. People curse me every day when they have it engaged and wish it was disengaged.
Hashtag Octathorp, Hashtag Octathurp, Hashtag Pound, Hashtag Number Sign, Hashtag Lumberyard, Hashtag Tiktok Do, Hashtag Musical Sharp if you're really lazy. Stop. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Avery Troubleman with same green span Katie Mingle and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and produced out of the offices of ArcSign an architecture and interiors firm in beautiful, downtown Oakland, California. I also invented the Caps Lock key. People curse me every day when they have it engaged and wish it was disengaged.|||#Octathorp，#Octathurp，#磅符号，#数字符号，#木材场，#TiktokDo，如果你真的很懒，就叫#音乐升号（Musical Sharp）。停。“99%隐形”本周由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼制作，山姆·格林斯潘、凯蒂·明格以及我罗曼·马斯共同参与。我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，制作地点位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的建筑与室内设计公司ArcSign的办公室。我还发明了大写锁定键（Caps Lock）。人们每天都在误触它时咒骂我，希望它从来没被设计出来。
You can find the show and hang out with other people who like the show on Facebook. All of the 99 PI producers use Twitter so search for 99% of his mom's Twitter and you will find us. But you're always welcome at our place at 99PI.org. Radio Tepio from PRX. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
You can find the show and hang out with other people who like the show on Facebook. All of the 99 PI producers use Twitter so search for 99% of his mom's Twitter and you will find us. But you're always welcome at our place at 99PI.org. Radio Tepio from PRX. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.|||你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目，并与喜欢这个节目的其他人一起交流。所有99PI的制作人都在使用推特，所以搜索“99% invisible”的推特就能找到我们。不过我们随时欢迎你光临我们的网站：99PI.org。来自PRX的Radio Tepio。来自PRX。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。